have you been wanting a reason to jump
back into the hardcore samurai action
game neo well then I've got some good
news because it just received a free
update that adds new missions and more
I'm Matt in this GameSpot news update is
ready to slice up some baddies Neos free
update adds new content and makes some
quality of life improvements new
submissions are now available but you'll
only be able to access them after
reaching the final part of the game and
if you're working towards the samurai of
legend trophy which requires you to
complete every mission in the game then
you don't have to worry these new levels
don't need to be completed to unlock it
other additions include more titles and
smithing texts both of which can be
unlocked in the new submissions there's
probably more where that came from so
make sure to LIKE and subscribe to be
the first to know when more new content
makes its way to the game the free patch
also adds the ability to pause the game
from inside the status menu use the left
and right buttons to skip items in the
equipment screen and more you can see
the rest of the changes on GameSpot calm
but if you want to test your skills in
brutal combat check out the first 10
minutes of Dark Souls 3 s DLC the Rings
City
[Music]
you